me dire la présentatrice ce soir je vais
vous parler du froid alors pourquoi
parler du froid à dunkerque
parce que le froid même si on ne sait
pas même si on ne vit pas tous les jours
c'est quelque chose qui a profondément
changé nos vies il continuer à vivre les
évolutions technologiques qu'on va
mettre entre être au point continueront
à changer le commandant patrick tous les
jours le froid les premières relations
entre l'âme et le froid c'était d'abord
pour son protégé
l'invention de la caverne l'invention de
la fenêtre l'invention de la maison
l'invention de la hutte l'invention du
feu s'était d'abord des façons de se
protéger de plasne danger mais entre
autres qui avaient le froid le froid
c'était la mort loeffel la chaleur la
ville lattre c'était là c'était la vie
plus un peu après au niveau des romains
des romains se sont rendu compte que
quand on avait du froid on était capable
de conserver pendant de longues périodes
des aliments et donc les romains
transporter leurs poissons entre le rhin
et rome
les pressions du rat qui était très coté
à rome en gardant la glace pendant toute
l'année
et puis en transportant du poisson
accompagné de glace ça continuer
jusqu'au moyen-âge jusqu'à la
renaissance et dans les châteaux y avait
des glacières qui permettait aux nobles
d'avoir des plats frais tout l'été ça a
changé vers 1850 avec la mention par
ferdinand carré delà du froid industriel
donc 7,7 ce scientifique français a
réussi à créer du froid par compression
d'un gaz puis détente et donc ce faisant
il nous a permis de créer le frigidaire
aujourd'hui frigo qui avait partout et
c'est devenu quelque chose de normal
un autre français charles tellier a
inventé la surgélation on est allé un
peu plus loin dans le froid un peu plus
bas en température et charles tellier a
eu l'idée de congeler la nourriture de
façon à pouvoir l'envoyer loin et la
garder longtemps grâce à des navires
comme celui ci charles tellier était
capable en 1860 à peu près d'envoyer
jusqu'à buenos aires des cargos entiers
plainte de plaintes de viande produite
en france la traversée dure et 140 jours
et à l'arrivée le vol l'avion n'était
encore consommables ça n'était pas
envisageable dix ans avant disons avant
on parlait de salaison on parlait de
fromage ont parlé de conservation par
des technologies qui était peu durable
et très peu transportable grâce à ces
technologies aujourd'hui ça c'est notre
quotidien
c'est notre quotidien c'est à dire que
tous les jours on est capable d'avoir
des produits frais d'où qu'il vienne
dans le monde et à notre table pour un
prix extrêmement raisonnable mais ce
n'est pas la seule révolution que le
froid a permis le plus important ça
d'abord été la liquéfaction des gaz de
l'air l'air c'est un gaz si on le
refroidit très fort on le conte danse et
ça devient des liquides exactement comme
un nuage quand il se condense devient de
la pluie et là on peut séparer les deux
par les deux portions principal de l'air
d'un côté en azote notre côté on à
l'oxygène avec l'oxygène on peut on l'a
séparé alimenter les malades sont les
poumons atteints et ça donne un bénéfice
pour la médecine
on peut avec la comment la zot brûler
les verrues et on peut aussi et surtout
traiter les grands sportifs en les
refroidissant très fort 2 minutes 1 -
110 degrés et un an un excellent
traitement pour les articulations pour
les muscles et tous les grands sportifs
français se commet ce qui bien mieux
olympique passe par ce type d'équipement
pour va finir leur masse musculaire
l'énorme innovation ça a été néanmoins
la cryopréservation le froid très très
froid là on parle de froid à moins 196
degrés par rapport à la tempère par
rapport aux 0 donc par rapport à la
glaciation de l'eau permet de conserver
des gamètes de conserver des tissus
pendant de très longues périodes et
conserver des gamètes s'est pas
uniquement pour le plaisir qu'on fait ça
ça permet par exemple de travailler sur
la comment la reproduction et son
amélioration
si aujourd'hui depuis des années 50 à
peu près on était capable d'améliorer
énormément les bleus et les génisses
pour faire des boeufs avec une
production de viande de très très bonnes
qualités et on est beaucoup et des
génisses capable de faire des vaches qui
produisent énormément de l'est c'est
parce qu'on était capable de
sélectionner les meilleurs reproduction
et ses techniques là elle se base sur la
conservation du sperme de taureau par la
cryogénie pendant pendant quelques
années la même façon
on a la capacité à sauvegarder des
espèces qui sont aujourd'hui en danger
que ce soit des plantes des champignons
que mon vrai tout à l'heure où des
commandes ou des animaux morceau de
tissu on a évidemment la capacité à
faire des banques de sperme est une
technique comme la fibre la fécondation
in vitro n'est possible que par le que
bien sûr et très réducteur que parce
qu'il existe entre autres des
technologies cryogéniques
il est évident que je remet pas du tout
en cause ici le travail des médecins qui
ont rendu ça possible et qui est bien
évidemment énorme mais il n'empêche que
ça a été quand même pour rendue possible
par la cryogénie un autre domaine où la
cryogénie est importante c'est laissons
les transports les véhicules que nous
conduisons aujourd'hui nous permettent
de travailler de traverser des étendues
aussi bien très chaude que très froide
les véhicules de l'armée aujourd'hui
sont capables de résister à des
températures extérieures de moins 80
degrés grâce à des matériaux à des
process des façons de faire qui conquit
qui résiste à ça pour mémoire faut se
rappeler que napoléon n'a pas réussi
envers la russie
principalement parce que son armée n'a
pas réussi à traiter des problèmes de
l'hiver dans ces pays là donc pour les
armes et la résistance à la température
et qui pour nos véhicules aussi combien
de temps en temps il fait froid dans le
coin c'est quelque chose pour l'aviation
bien évidemment un avion quand il est
dans le ciel rôle la température
extérieure est très basse après ça peut
aussi les vallées jusqu'à -50 degrés est
bien évidemment encore plus pour un
satellite et dans l'espace
il ya plus de température en espace qui
a plus rien autour donc la température
présent à quelques degrés par rapport au
zéro absolu
l'espace est un grand pardon je suis
allé un peu trop vite
récit merci un gros consommateurs de
technologies cryogéniques aussi pour les
motorisations
les moteurs fusées comme celui ci c'est
moteur vulcain qui fait partir l'ariane
5 utilise un mélange d'oxygène liquide 3
183 degrés et d'hydrogène liquide - 200
et quelques degrés sans technologies
cryogéniques sur les réservoirs sont
technologies cryogéniques dans le moteur
des pompes capable de travailler à cette
température
aujourd'hui on ne serait pas capable
d'envoyer ce genre d'objet dans l'espace
et s'il n'y a pas de satellite
pas de gps il ya beaucoup moins de
communication n'y a pas d'image de la
terre il ya moins de facilité à prévoir
la météo
donc moins de facilité à faire des
commandes à déterminer la date des semis
des récoltes et les choses comme ça
toutes ces technologies cryogéniques on
permette supporte le monde dans lequel
on vit de façon de façon toujours un
prix identique les technologies
cryogéniques dans le domaine des
transports ont permis la création des
lignes de métro quand on a des sols
gorgés d'eau il est impossible de
creuser un tunnel dedans lourds entre
répare tout cela ne serait pas faisable
quand il ya vraiment beaucoup d'eau la
seule solution c'est de congeler le sol
ça a été fait pour la première fois à
paris en 1905
et c'est encore été fait à paris en
région parisienne pour le creusement
d'un tunnel de l'a86 enfin bon jour
comme le froid est là le fait qu'on
croit capable de refroidir des corps des
capteurs à très basse température
c'est ce qui permet de faire des mesures
extrêmement précise le froid c'est quand
un corps ne bouge pas pendant les atomes
du corps ne bouge pas et quand les
atomes du corps d'accord ne bouge pas le
capteur qui composaient par ce score
permet peut recueillir les infimes
variations de température les ondes
magnétiques qui sont émises par quelque
chose et c'est grâce à ça qu'on est
capable de faire des irm ou comment
qu'on est capable d'avoir des images qui
viennent cette élite comme hubble
tous ces capteurs médicaux hyper précis
tous ces capteurs scientifiques hyper
précis tout ce qui permet aujourd'hui de
faire des découvertes scellier c'est
principalement permis par des
technologies cryogéniques sans aller
dans l'eau si compliqué l'industrie et
les emplois même dans le dunkerquois
c'est beaucoup la halle s'est beaucoup
là que j'ai dit vous avez là des photos
de deux usines qui sont tout près de
chez nous lusine d'air liquide qui est
l'une des plus grosses d'europe qui
produit dans de l'azoté liquide l'air
liquide c'est les gaz de l'air de la zot
à moins 196 degrés de l'oxygène à -183
degré et vous avez lusine de polir de
polimeri qui produit du polyuréthane nos
comptes
ou du polyéthylène et qui donc
travaillent avec une partie du procès sa
moins 110 degrés la cryogénie c'est pas
que des spécialistes c'est aussi des
emplois industriels
et puis bien sûr vous avez le terminal
méthanier de dunkerque lng est en
construction
trois cubes de gaz naturel liquéfié qui
contiendront 190 mille mètres cubes de
gnl
c'est énorme ça permet d'alimenter 20 %
de la consommation électrique française
de ghazir française pardon et sa
technologie de commande du froid permet
de transporter de grosses quantités
d'énergie entre des pays lointains des
producteurs comme le qatar le yémen et
la france où les roule
comment ou l'angleterre ou l'espagne
alors que entre les deux pays il ya soit
des maires soit des montagnes soit des
pays qui sont en guerre pour résumer sur
la partie actuelle
on a aujourd'hui en france énormément
d'entreprises qui sont dépendants leur
marché sur le domaine de l'ingénierie
on peut citer par exemple en gaz de
france suez qui a inventé le gnl on peut
citer technip 1 bien sûr qui est
aujourd'hui l'ingénierie de référence
dans ce domaine de la cryogénie une
entreprise française sof regaz saipem
total leader de la production du gnl
dans le monde edf
entrepose à dunkerque cmp dunkerque cmp
dunkerque fabrique aujourd'hui les tôles
des réservoirs qui sont les réservoirs
de gnl qui sont en cours de construction
à yamal dans la péninsule de loeb
là bas il ya deux types de problèmes de
cryogénie a d'abord le produit qu'on va
manipuler c'est à dire le gnl 360 degrés
et puis loeb c'est tout temps ou presque
au pôle nord il y fait moins deux degrés
les habits que père que portent les gens
leur permettent de travailler une heure
au bout d'une heure il faut rentrer à
l'abri soit changée et se réchauffer
mais c'est abi là sont des habits qui
ont été conçus pour les technologies de
froid par les entreprises de entre
autres françaises ça c'était de passer
maintenant on va parler un peu
prospective que peut nous amener là
technologies cryogéniques dans les
années à venir
eh bien d'abord la première chose
première évolution qui viendra c'est sur
la santé première chose les greffons un
greffon c'est un morceau d'une personne
qui est décédée
on va réutiliser dans le cadre d'une
autre personne ce qui est très important
ce n'était pas de le conserver le plus
longtemps possible de façon à s'assurer
qu'on va trouver un couple donneur
receveur qui soit compatible
aujourd'hui on est sur quelques heures
quelques dizaines d'heures ans maximum
l'enjeu de la cryogénie c'est être
capable de congeler de faire descendre
la température d'un greffon de façon à
le garder encore plus longtemps donc de
pouvoir le transporter plus loin donc de
pouvoir avoir du temps pour préparer
bloc opératoire pour préparer le
receveur c'est un enjeu de santé
important parce que les greffes quelque
chose de fondamental cette technologie
la has intéresse aussi l'agroalimentaire
parce que l'agroalimentaire a besoin de
conserver la texture de ce qui vous vend
comme produit issu comme produits
surgelés et ces deux mondes se sont
rejoints pour un projet de recherche qui
est en cours actuellement sur le
dunkerque à côté vous avez une mouche
c'est le premier organisme vivant qu'on
a congelé puis re dégeler et qui était
encore vivant après normalement cette
mouche là vers -5 degrés vous sans faire
quelque chose comme ça elle même est
bien la part des technologies de
conservation cryogénique
on a réussi à la garder vivantes alors
qu'elle est descendue à moins 18 degrés
c'est une mouche aujourd'hui fin du
monde dans le futur
on va essayer avec t
des animaux un peu plus gros les humains
parce que la cryogénisation c'est la
seule façon de transporter des humains
vers d autres planètes dans des systèmes
très lointain quand le voyage dure 50
ans 60 ans on peut absolument pas
envisagé de passer sous entendant une
fusée ou dans un satellite
c'est impossible on viendrait faut donc
il faut absolument être priorisé la nasa
a lancé un projet de crayonnés de
cryogénisation d'être humain complet
alors évidemment ils n'ont pas essayé
tout de suite avec quelqu'un ça va
prendre du temps
c'est un programme qui est censé durer
30 ans 30 ans ça veut dire que dans
cette salle la plupart d'entre vous le
verrons ouvert cette possibilité
d'inclure génie dans le cadre de notre
vie évidemment ça posera des problèmes
éthiques parce que déjà aujourd'hui des
entreprises comme apple et google ont
proposé à leurs salariés féminine de
congés leurs ovaires leurs canettes
pardon leur revue suisse est moins de
plonger leurs ovules de façon pour être
capable de garder la partie productive
de leur vie où elles sont le plus
efficaces
trente ans on va dire entre 20 ans et 40
ans et puis de faire les enfants après
forcément c'est une vraiment très bien
on est évidemment contre normand la
question a été posée alors imaginez ce
qui se passerait si on pouvait congé des
gens ce que ce serait un droit et un
devoir qu'est ce que ce sera en termes
de prison ça posera des débats mais
néanmoins ça ouvre aussi des portes et
des capacités pour les transports la
cryogénie aussi va amener des choses
alors je parle pas des voitures pour
lesquelles éventuel valent le futur
c'est évidemment la voiture électrique
je parle pas non plus des trains qui ont
résolu leur problème de pollution depuis
très longtemps et que les caténaires et
les trains électriques mais je vous
parle des bateaux et du transport
routier
ces deux façons transporter le fluvial
au 6e round transportés sont aujourd'hui
pose aujourd'hui un problème de santé
publique car vous avez entendu il ya
encore très peu de temps on a beaucoup
parlé des particules fines et la
commande du problème des diesels le
premier d elle sera très vite résolu
pour les voitures pour les bateaux pour
les pour les camions c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué
et donc pour ces objets là le futur
c'est le gaz naturel liquéfié comme
combustible dans les navires et dans les
camions c'est pas une vue de l'esprit
fluxys a déjà installé à furnes donc
trois kilomètres d'ici une station
service qui dessert les poids lourds en
gaz naturel liquéfié donc à combustible
à moi 163 degré où les poids lourds
peuvent venir faire leur place
ça pose des nouveaux problèmes des
problèmes de procédure avec la conduisit
dans 63 degrés ou peut pas avoir un
pistolet comme ça qu'on tient à la main
c'est pas possible parce que sinon la
main dresse collé sur le pistolet ont
c'est embêtant
donc il ya tout à toute une nouvelle
chaîne technologique à mettre en place
mais c'est en cours et ça se fait et
l'objectif général c'est d'aller vers
une beaucoup moins de pollution sur le
long des routes le long des grands axes
de transport et le long des côtes pour
la partie navire il ya aujourd'hui une
directive tabac la directive ckac qui
impose qu'il y ait plus de combustible
souffrait surtout cela comment toute la
partie de la commande
or jusqu'en haut de la baltique et
réaliser ceci nécessite que de convertir
les bateaux soit avec des combustibles
différente basée sur le pétrole soit là
aussi avec du gel le grand port maritime
de dunkerque a lancé un appel à
manifester dans manifestation d'intérêt
que dunkerque lng et les partenaires
nous avons répondu pour mettre en place
sur le dunkerquois un soudage le
bénéfice net attendu seiler côtiers et
c'est donc un vraiment une réponse au
problème de santé publique qui ont été
évoqués moult fois parlé par les
ministres toutes ces nouvelles
technologies nécessitent qu'on vérifie
tout un tout un tas de choses alors par
exemple à dunkerque on s'intéresse au
vieillissement des aciers qui sont
soumis à des cycles de froid et de
chaleur
on connais très bien ce qui se passe
avec les aciers canton les chauffe on
connaît beaucoup moins bien ce qui se
passe avec les aciers canton les
refroidit très fort là ce qui est normal
à -30° devient complètement cassant donc
pour la cryogénie on utilise acier
inoxydable néanmoins si on passe son
temps elle réchauffe et à le refroidir
qu'est ce qui lui arrive pour qu'on est
en train de regarder ça gèle des études
bien sûr aller
les conditions de sécurité sont déjà
bien bien au point mais on vérifie que
sur une durée de vie de 50 ans dans des
ouvrages comme des camions com dcom
train des péniches d eau pour tous là
les avoir il y aura pas de problème la
même façon à grenoble on s'intéresse à
la supraconductivité dans les moteurs de
ces deux de tous ces objets bougeant la
supraconductivité permet de gagner
énormément en termes de rendement des
moteurs dont on pourrait encore en plus
diminuer la consommation de ces de ses
ouvrages
et puis pour transférer le produit d'un
endroit à un autre il faut s'intéresser
aux flexible et il faut s'intéresser
éventuellement à des matériaux souples
a lille on s'intéresse aux flexible en
lien avec des entreprises de premier
plan
je peux pas vous dire tout sur ses
projets de recherche parce qu'ils sont
confidentielles aujourd'hui et à roubaix
on s'occupe de commandes de concevoir
des matériaux souples
qui seront capables de résister à des
températures cryogénique a naguère autre
exemple on cherche à trouver des
matériaux qui quand on les fait traversé
par un courant électrique génère du
froid ça existe déjà un petit peu ce
qu'on appelle l'effet peltier il ya
beaucoup de glace hier qu'ils sont déjà
sierre de camping qui sont équipés comme
ça mais c'est pas du tout efficace
donc on cherche des matériaux beaucoup
plus efficace pour faire ça et l'idée
c'est quoi c'est d'avoir un verre de
bière qui comprend la bien on a une pile
ou en recharge sur une clé usb
et puis hop on a alors dû dire qu'il
fallait bien ça pour on peut boire on
peut avoir un bol qui permet de
construire de prendre la glace même en
plein soleil la glace restant froides
on peut aussi avoir des frigidaires de
forme quelconque on peut installer un
frigidaire complètement dans un endroit
qui serait pas possible puisque on
aurait le matériau lui-même qui ferait
qui générerait le froid pour des
industriels disposaient de ce type de
matériau permet d'avoir des isolants qui
sont parfait puisque le matériau
lui-même génère réel froid et donc dont
pourrait conserver le gaz naturel
liquéfié pendant d'ex pleinement longue
période
parce qu'il y aurait plein de nouveaux
usages avec des matériaux souples on
pourrait faire des fusées moins lourde
avec des matériaux souples
on pourrait baisser les coûts dans tout
un tas de commandes objet aujourd'hui
relativement cher du fait des matériaux
qu'on utilise pour la cryogénie dernière
révolution qui va arriver c'est la
révolution environnementale
deux des principales technologies qu'on
utilise pour lutter contre l'effet de
serre sont les technologies cryogéniques
d'une part on à la technologie de
l'hydrogène l'hydrogène pour le
conserver il faut le refroidir et le
liquéfier si vous essayez de ged dans un
récipient quelconque hydrogène essais
atomiques sont tellement petits qui sont
bons ils passent et sage paie donc la
seule façon de vraiment bien le
conserver c'est de liquéfier savamment
en plus d'avoir une meilleure densité
énergétique et donc là dedans la
direction hydrogène étant à moins de 120
degrés c'est une technologie cryogénique
qui arrivera puis la deuxième
technologie cryogénique qui va
probablement émerger rapidement c'est la
liquéfaction du co2 on dit tout ce qu'on
veut c'est pas comment on veut récupérer
le co2 et s'en débarrasser mais on ne
dit jamais comment comment on va faire
pour le transporter le co2 pour s'en
débarrasser il faut l'envoyer dans des
gisements
est relié déplétés ou dans les choses
comme ça qui sont loin donc il fallait
transporter sur de très longues
distances sont serbes
ce sera le liquéfier et blanc menée par
des bateaux au point on s'en
débarrassera en injectant dans le temps
des champs pour arriver à la conclusion
la chaîne l'a globalement la cryogénie
c'est un domaine important dans la vie
de tous les jours
pas très connue très discret mais qui
est en plein dynamisme est en plein
bouleversement
à dunkerque avec l'industriel la
communauté urbaine et comment élus
locaux on a fondé une école qui ont créé
une association aujourd'hui le résultat
ce que quelques années après la création
d'adam en 2011
on a 2 5 millions d'euros de recherche
collaborative en cours on a créé un
centre de formation professionnelle on a
créé une licence pro on a comme en douze
étudiants qui travaillent douze césars
qui sont enfin de faire de la recherche
50 intervenants qui encadrent ou qui
aident à cet égard et on a 40 à peu près
40 étudiants en formation sur des
licences pros qui sont en cours à l'ulco
dans le domaine de la cryogénie le côté
exploratoire pour moi industriel c'est
d'arriver à créer quelque chose comme ça
c'est à dire en fait un lieu de
rencontre c'est en cela je pense que je
suis un j'espère contribuer à faire se
rencontrer autour d'une même table
autour d'une même thématique à la fois
des académiques qui ont besoin de
développer leurs connaissances
scientifiques des territoires qui ont
besoin de créer des emplois parce que
quand on dit recherche en 10 derrière
emplois induits et des industriels qui
ont envie de faire du bizness envie de
faire globalement des affaires innopole
c'est un lieu où on met tout ça ensemble
en synergie autour d'une thématique pour
le développement merci